good morning everyone first of all thank
you for resisting the urge to get lunch
and staying here instead I know it's
been a long day I'll and yesterday as
well so thank you for being here I hope
you'll find it worth your while
so this talk is actually a little bit of
a departure for me I largely do defense
and automation oriented talks but this
one I thought was a message that needed
to get out anyway so I thought let's try
it out this way in a different way so
this is a little bit more attack focused
red team style focused it's not I will
talk a little bit about defenses but
it's going to be largely attack focused
especially given the time we have so
this is called an attackers view of
serverless and graph QL now server less
by itself graph QL by itself are
obviously there's a lot of content in
there you have a lot of different ways
in which they can get compromised and I
have a lot of different ways in which
you can secure them however I thought it
is important to cover both these things
in conjunction simply because you are
going to see a lot of these type of
stacks being deployed moving forward is
what I feel I'm not in the prediction
business but I feel that this is what is
going to happen moving forward this is
me my name is Abhay I run we fortify we
are an application security company we
do have we do a lot of training pen
testing architecture reviews threat
modeling and so on in fact we have also
a lot of cool open source projects one
is our correlation tool which is
orchestron which is the community
version is on github we have in fact a
lot of this conference is about threat
modeling and we have a threat modeling
as code framework where you can use
threat models and build them into your
CIC the pipelines that's called threat
playbook you want to look at it you can
we're building in a lot of new features
on that as well
two weeks before coming into this
conference we released the new open
source tool called DV fasts or dam
vulnerable functions as a service
these are intentionally vulnerable
serverless functions that you can use
deploy on your own
Amazon lambda stack and run it and test
it out and see how attacks on serverless
functions work again don't run this on
production don't run this on your AWS
account on your workplace that's not
obviously gonna be a good thing but to
learn how things go you can probably try
out DB fast we have a bunch of dvf a
sticker so after the talking can come
and see me and I can hand you give you
guys some stickers for devfs so this is
not the first time I've spoken about
serverless at this event we just
finished a training we just came off a
training on serverless
on 22nd 23rd serverless containers and
kubernetes so this is kind of an
extension of what we were talking about
that I do see some familiar faces in the
room so thank you for coming out so
first of all I want to say this I'm not
some kind of an expert of any sort so
please don't expect that I'm gonna give
you a lot of nuggets of wisdom it's not
gonna happen it's probably there's going
to be a lot of attack focused stuff
again I learned from the community as
much as I try and give back so obviously
please keep that in mind so let's get
started so today's session
I'm gonna quickly cover this because I
do have some demos so I would like to
keep some time for questions and answers
so I'm gonna start off with a gentle
introduction the serverless
and graph QL now this I'm sure a lot of
folks in the room probably are not quite
familiar especially security folks may
not be 100% familiar with watch level I
say is what graph QL is so I'm going to
do a quick recap of this again it's not
gonna be a very large recap I'm just
going to try and stick to the essentials
then I'm going to look at an attackers
view of serverless itself so we look at
attackers view of fasts fasces functions
as a service and it's not the only type
of server less thing around right you do
have back into the service you have
functions as a service I want to focus
on functions as a service for the stock
again the reference point is largely
going to be with AWS lambda and not of
course you do have Google Cloud
functions you have as your functions you
have all of these different fast
implementations or fast frameworks I'm
going to focus on lambda because it's
probably the most used again the
concepts in here probably apply
elsewhere as well so you can use the
same concepts graph QL of course is a
standard technology you can use graph QL
is pretty widely used in fact it's
getting heavily used in a lot of stacks
and a lot of modern stacks you would see
that graph QL is becoming extensively
used especially where there is a lot of
mobile footprint right when there is a
lot of mobile footprint you see graph QL
being extensively used because you want
to have you know multiple clients
working with the same application API
style environment so you see a lot of
graph QL of course I have demos and we
will conclude with some understanding of
what is an attackers perspective of
these two types of technologies and the
the conglomeration of these two
technologies essentially that's what I'm
going to be talking about today of
course I do have a lot of demos and as
always whenever whenever demos are
involved I have to say a silent prayer
to the demo gods
I'd really like you all to say the same
prayer for me then there are some live
demos they do I do have some videos but
largely live demo so I'm going to try
and see if I don't mess it up entirely
right so let's get started
with server lists right so server lists
are what we call functions as a service
is something that has a lot of different
meanings especially serverless because
you have things that you run backend
authentication systems with which you
don't need to maintain infrastructure
for like octa whatever it is that
service our DynamoDB where you run
databases that are completely managed
for you service all of these things are
server lists as well however what we are
going to be talking about is functions
as a service where you can deploy single
purpose functions on to a cloud
environment or you can run them of
course even on containerized
environments or even virtual machine'
environments but typically you see them
running on your cloud service providers
like AWS Google cloud and so on and so
forth you do have some open source
variants like open fasts and I think FN
and of course iBM has their own open
wisk and so on and so forth
so functions of service essentially is
us trying to move faster right so we had
monoliths where you have this massive
application with a ton of features and
we realize that oh my god its hellish
thing to maintain this it's gonna take
years and years by the time we make a
feature or we try and release a new
feature we break 300 other features and
a lot of problems happen so you can't do
your DevOps and all of that stuff with
monoliths right a lot of its in fact
that you can't do it it's that much more
difficult so all of us started espousing
hey let's go to micro services right
let's start building smaller services
smaller more independent discrete
services that you can use so let us say
you have user management does one
service billing is one service payment
does one service purchase is one service
you might have a bunch of services and
you obviously have different stacks
you probably deploy them differently
however they're all talking to each
other through some kind of a message
queue or some kind of a a glue that you
have in form of a message queue and so
on and so forth so you typically had
monoliths which became micro services
and then we realized why not make this a
smaller unit of computing we realized
okay during sign up there is only our
create user function that's being
invoked a lot right during a sign-up
process let's say we are a hot new
startup and we want people to sign up
for our service like in white only thing
before we actually issue in whites then
you obviously see that the create only
function is being used lot more in our
micro service then we realize that if we
want to scale this particular function
independently we probably need for it to
have its own compute environment it
should probably scale on its own have
its own set up have its own set of
dependencies and run with it right so
that's why you would probably have a
scenario where you have create user
which is a single function deployed as a
function on lambda or Google Cloud or
whatever it is and that's being called
millions and millions of times and
obviously you have
we do whatever extent you want and
that's the only function getting used so
you have a bunch of different functions
that you're using and these functions in
in totality make up your application or
what used to be a micro service or
hopefully a monolith but again a lot of
people just try and push these two into
this and say that how we are using
functions as a service but that's also
some of the issues that they face but
anyway this is ideally what we're going
for we're going for the smallest unit of
compute we realized that we wanted just
this this individual function to run and
that function obviously has its
arguments and it produces some output
and that's typically what your function
is right so functions are triggered via
events now any function can be triggered
via events now when a user sends an HTTP
GET or a post or a put call that is an
event functions can also be triggered we
have third-party events now let us say
you upload a file on s3 and the function
is triggered as soon as the upload
happens or an object is created in s3
that is an event right user sends a text
message to your messaging gateway a
function is triggered based on that text
message and some action takes place that
is an event or you get a message queue
your message queue on sqs gets a
notification or a message coming in and
you trigger a function based off of that
that is a third party that is also a
function getting triggered by a third
party events so you have various sources
of events that are triggering functions
not just you are typically API or web
services style functions that you used
to know so functions are not only used
for web services or to create API you
can also use them for reacting to
different events across your throughout
environment or across your deployment so
to speak so now what typically happens
when an event is triggered is that they
would trigger either a container or a
micro VM in Amazon's case it's we've
learned that it's micro VMs they use
their own micro VM framework this micro
VM comes up runs the function and
immediately goes into a frozen state
right now the frozen state
fought to make sure that you don't
really run any background processes
after that the ideal thing is you run
the function and that's it
it's a one and done kind of a thing so
it's like you're CGI right if you think
about it it's very similar to how CGI is
used to execute where you had individual
processes getting spawn every single
time requests used to come in in this
case of course there is a huge amount of
difference because you have your cloud
scalability you have scalability built
in by default again you don't have any
they don't have any ports functions
don't really have any ports you are
accessing them through the API gateway
but the API gateway is the one that's
actually handling the communication but
the function by itself is not handling
any network communication itself right
so there's no real network attack model
so to speak however there are different
things that can go wrong so that is
typically it triggers a container or a
VM and of course it executes something
or whatever the function you want it to
execute and then it freezes post
execution and of course there are
different states I'm not going to get
into the states they're warm and cold
and so on and so forth but there are
different ways of tracking all of that
stuff but I'm not going to get into that
the idea is a container spawns or a VM
spawns runs the function brings it down
that's typically what happens in a
functions as a service scenario right so
functions are usually single purpose you
can't do too many things within a
function you can't do I do this run a
user or create the user then you know
validate something else with the user do
something else so you can't run too many
dependent activities on a single
function you probably need to call other
functions when you want to do that but
ideally speaking you have single purpose
when a function is in play right again
no ports so the function by itself does
not have any ports it's not exposed on
port 80 or 443 or whatever it is it is
called by different events of course
those events or those event sources
might have their own service ports and
so on but typically functions by
themselves don't have ports right they
don't really have the network attack
layer included so that is one thing you
also they don't really have States so
one of the things that you would find
really hard to do with the form
is do state management to the function
because the function kills itself as
soon as the function is executed so
that's something that you have to keep
in mind right and they're short-lived
one of the things you should keep in
mind is that you can't run a let us say
one of the things that I would love to
do is run as app scan on a function at
least a one hours app scan that's not
going to happen simply because functions
probably timeout that I think there's a
maximum of five minutes I'm not sure
fifteen minutes okay there's a maximum
or time limit that you can give a
function there's a maximum memory that
you can allocate product for a
particular function so you have these
constraints but if you have architected
your application to work with those
constraints obviously your application
would work with those constraints given
whatever you've configured the functions
for like I mentioned before your events
could come from multiple sources so very
commonly things like s3 whenever an
object is created on s3 you trigger a
function whenever an object is coming
through a message queue you trigger a
function of course when a user sends an
API request to your function which is
behaving like an API it would come
through the API gateway or it could come
through your IOT scenario where you
would have a network of sensors that are
essentially sending or publishing events
to a pubsub interface and that is
triggering a function in the background
so you have a lot of these different use
cases that functions can be used for you
can also use functions for scheduled
events right so let us say want or
something to run every five minutes or
every day or every year so a lot of
common use cases in an Amazon scenario
is running a function every year to
rotate your kms keys so that's a very
common use case to use functions for so
a lot of times you would run scheduled
events as part of functions so you can
do that quite easily with functions a
lot of the function as a service tooling
like chalice or arc chords or claudia GS
and all of that stuff allows you to
configure these events or react to these
events so you have these events that you
can work with as I mentioned before you
deploy your function as a zip file with
all the dependencies that you need and
in the amazons case of course you have a
cloud formation template that
requires you to create the function
create the log groups that it has all of
the necessary privileges for that to run
the function is invoked whenever the
user calls of course it invokes either a
container or in Amazon's case of micro
VM and then of course they are frozen
once the function is executed so let me
just quickly run a function deployment
for you right now this is a function
that just gets in it just you are
allowed to so it uploads the Hamel file
and stores it in the database somewhere
that's really what this function is
doing so it's getting a Hamel file as
input as an upload and it's storing the
Alpha in the database I'm I'm just going
to look at I'm going to want to show you
how you can apply this I'm going to be
using chalice for deployment so I'm just
gonna so so this is my function so you
can see this this is all it is it has a
single route I think it has two routes
it has a test route and it has a yeah
Mille upload route and that's all it's
doing so when you test it of course it
sends back a success test and when you
upload a Hamel what it does is that it
stores the amyl I'm not I'm not it
written the storage code but ideally it
should write it in the contents of the
amylin to a DynamoDB table that's all
it's doing right so you can upload a
Hamel and that's what it really does so
you can look at you can see that this
behaves very typically like an API right
so you can see that is very similar to
flask or any other web service framework
that you would have seen where you can
write something like this and get it
running up and running so deployment is
pretty easy as well most of the times
you have tools that will do the
deployments for you so you have tools
like chalice you have tools like
Claudia's yes you have tools they are
codes all you have to do is there is a
particular config file or some kind of a
you know dot directory that you have to
include as part of the function what
these deployment tools would do is first
of all identify the app that is running
your function load that as a handler and
essentially package all the dependencies
store that in a zip
file and then send it over to AWS in
uploaded to s3 and then of course from
there the function becomes operational
many of them also do I am privileged
management for you as in they create
your roles that is required for the
function to run they might allow you to
allow the function to write log events
the cloud watch all of that stuff right
so you typically have a lot of I am
privileged that is assigned by the
deployment managers that's also another
security gotcha simply because if the
deploy if the deployment manager gives
you more permissions or privileges than
necessary there's a good chance that you
could get hosed because of that so the
deployment manager is kind of take over
the process from now on so you have
different deployment manager is like
Zappa Claudia Diaz chalice I'm using one
from AWS called chalice so I'm just
going to deploy this function so it's a
very simple thing so you can see in my
in my directory I have the app dot pipe
which is the actual code payload Rama is
not important
requirements in our text is my Python
requirements file which is gonna pull
from PI pi when function is loaded in I
also have my custom Python libraries or
dependencies in my vendor directory
that's essentially what this is so let's
say I have a bunch of custom Python code
I want to introduce or wanna import into
this function I'm going to put that in
my vendor directory that's what's really
happening here it's reasonably simple
I'm just going to run a command which is
chalice deploy and what this does it
creates a zip file as I mentioned before
it creates a zip file and then of course
it also creates the it updates the
policy so let us say I made a change in
the I am role or policy that I need it
updates the policy updates the function
I've already deployed this function a
bunch of times or just runs a update of
that existing deployment you can bring
it down equally simply with a chalice
delete or a challenge this time I'm not
sure which command but one of those to
calm our chalice delete I think it's
chalice destroy that allows you to do
that there are a lot of deployment
managers that also allow you to convert
otherwise traditionally monolithic or
micro-services style apps to functions
as a service so there's one called try
server less dark I don't know how many
of you it's called SLS
in charge so what that does is that you
can write out a yama respect like very
much like you can write a kubernetes
pecker so on you can write out and say
that this is my application my function
is in this particular app dot pie I need
Python 3.6 or nord 8.1 or whatever it is
you can mention the runtime environment
that it needs to work the deployment
file that it needs right and it
generates the file and applies at 501
that's whatever you need it to do so you
can see that the function has now been
deployed on AWS there is a AR N and the
air and it's a particular a RN and
there's a REST API because since this is
access through the API gateway it also
gives you a REST API that you can use to
access the function in in the event that
your function does not have any rest api
like functionalities it would just
deploy the function and not give you a
nearest API URL to just tell you the
real function is deployed and of course
you can call it where are those
third-party triggers right so that's
what your so just the a quick demo of
the deployment of a function is a
service now I'm going to quickly get
into a little bit of background on graph
QL and then we look at the attack of
course
so graph QL is essentially an API query
language right so what it does is that
instead of you writing a hundreds of
thousands of API routes what graph QL
allows you to do is query your final
database so our query or API through a
layer which it provides and this layer
essentially allows you to query specific
information you don't have to
essentially query the whole thing a lot
of times for instance if you look at the
github API you will see that if you do
that a typical REST API you would see
that a ton of information comes back to
you right you would see a ton of massive
JSON coming back every time you query
say fetch all my repositories and I have
a bunch of repositories it would give me
a massive JSON object that has all my
repository names it has all the
necessary fields allocated with that all
the necessary attributes associated with
that all that comes back it's that's a
pretty huge data set now what graph QL
allows you to do is through a specific
query language specify saying look
I want my repositories I just want the
URL of my repositories I don't want
anything else so just give me my
repositories and the URL of those
repositories and what it does is that it
comes back as JSON except that in this
case it's optimized and it only gives
you or it returns there your
repositories with the URLs of those
repositories and nothing else you can
use graph QL to insert data which is
called a mutation you can use it to
query data which is of course a query
you can also use graph QL to do
subscriptions so let us say you are you
want to publish real-time information
somewhere whenever data gets added to
your API
what graph QL does is through a
subscription would trigger a
notification to some webhook or whatever
it is that you want to do right so graph
QL has a bunch of functionality it's
it's from Facebook by the way so I think
it's now a independent foundation but it
started off as a Facebook project but
now it's kind of become a little bigger
than that so they've they've broken it
up into a separate entity is what I've
heard I'm not 100% sure on that
so rest versus graph QL so this is
typically what you would do with REST
API right so you would probably be
familiar with something like this where
you have API organizations list etc
except where you have a ton of URLs you
have a ton of routes and each of these
routes need to be configured you need to
write the business logic for each of
these routes now with graph QL all of
this goes away and just becomes this
right so essentially say use this slash
graph tool and all of the queries that
you do are handled by that graph QL
resolver or that graphical layer that
allows you to query stuff mutate stuff
and so on and so forth so let's so you
typically have graph QL types which you
could query or you could insert or you
could subscribe to these go into
resolvers this is where your business
logic or your function actually plays in
where you would write something saying
ok it mutates so let us say I want to
add a user I would create a mutation and
this user would be added to my database
through the code that I write in the
resolver so the resolver essentially
takes care of managing the actual
business logic of what's happening with
in my graphic you laugh right so there's
a database of course it can talk to
multiple databases at a time you can
hook it up to not just a database you
can also hook it up to another API so
let us say you want to hook it up to my
sequel if you wanna pull it up the [ __ ]
you want to hook it up to elasticsearch
you want to hook it up to another API
you can do that and it would give you a
very similar representation so the again
you have in with graph QL you have
different types of servers you have
different types of products that have
become pretty popular one is the Apollo
product which is which is become quite a
dominant standard when it comes to graph
QL especially on JavaScript Python is
something called graphene which I use
quite a bit again you have different I
don't know about the other languages but
you typically see Apollo graphene I
think graphene has language bindings for
multiple by multiple languages apart
from just Python and JavaScript so
simple terms again you can define object
types in field so which means you can
say hey this is a user user has name age
email password whatever right you can
define those types and fields you can
make queries which are essentially
select statements you can make mutations
which are insert or update statements
you have scalars where you can say that
this is a custom data type that I want
to use in my data definition you can use
that as a scalar so let's say you want
to allow JSON just JSON to work with
your data and you just want to allow
that either query or mutate you want to
allow a very loosely scoped kind of a
query you can use scalars and of course
the resolve were that actually is your
function that translates all of these
type systems into your database queries
so your function essentially is written
to translate all of this stuff into your
database queries so let me just give you
a quick tour of graph QL I have in fact
this is not a fully than a graphical 8
so I'm converting a lot of thread
playbook into graph QL so one of the
layers that I'm going to show you now is
how thread PlayBook works with last ul
so let me just show you how it works
it's it's quite simple to understand so
I've already I think I'm already running
the server
yeah that's already running so I'm just
going to access this URL so this is my
graph QL so graph QL you have a lot of
client-side tools that allow you to
query and use graph QL you can see that
it's pretty much near real-time right
you can actually query real time with
query changes in real time you are the
other and you can see that there is only
one URL that I am actually query I'm not
clearing a bunch of URLs so all of these
are the the query itself goes as an HTTP
POST request so the query itself goes as
an HTTP POST request and that's how it
works so you don't have put delete all
of that stuff you just have HTTP POST
one of the other things in graph QL is
you don't have HTTP error codes as well
you just have HTTP 200 the error is
always inside of the JSON that comes
back right the data that actually comes
back the error is in that data set or
the error is represented in there if you
don't have 400 you don't have 500 you
typically don't see standard HTTP error
codes like that so let's look at a quick
query so I have a bunch of objects that
I have written in here you have I have
vulnerabilities projects thread playbook
is about user story driven threat
modeling so I have user stories abuser
stories and so on and so forth so let's
look at how I can query something like
this right so let's look at a simple
query for vulnerabilities now I'm going
to query all the ones except I'm not
going to query all the fields I just
want the name and I want the description
that's all I want so let's start with
the name first I'm gonna say name and
I'm gonna run the query and it's just
gonna come back with the names of all
the vulnerabilities in my database right
that's it it's just all the
vulnerabilities in my database and all
the names of those Werner abilities so
I'm not querying any unnecessary
information if this was a REST API I
would say you know once and it would
come back with this massive JSON
structure with the name the cwe the
description the observation the none of
that stuff the requests the response and
if it was zapped it will probably come
back with HTTP requests HTTP response
method body all of that stuff I don't
need any of that stuff I just need the
name let's say now I need to
we read the description I just query the
description and it automatically queries
that description comes back with the
description so I can do that I can also
start quickly querying nested objects
right so I can say query query this
object which is user stories and every
user story in my case has a short name
and I also want a query the abuser story
is related to that user story so that's
the feature here so every user story as
a bunch of associated abuser stories
with it so I'm going to query the abuses
object and I'm gonna say give me the
short names of the abuses as well as the
description of those abuse cases that
I'm writing so it gives me the user
story which is the short name here and
all of the abuser story is associated
with that user story so this way I can
actually customize my queries quite
extensively right I can write multiple
select queries in the same query I don't
have to query one at a time or all at a
time it's not our one or all kind of a
thing I can actually get quite you know
flexible with the way I query the system
or I mutate the system and so on and so
forth
similar thing with mutations rotations
are pretty simple as well so mutations
essentially in this case I've written
only one mutation so I'm going to show
you that mutation so I have one mutation
which essentially adds a project or
creates a project so I'm going to say
create project I give it a name and I
say wasp EPS ik Kelly 2019 and I come
back with the new with the status of
that mutation and I also come back with
the project and I come back with a
project name so once I update or a
mutate the project I come back with the
status of the update of the insert and I
also I want to show the name of that
particular project that I've just
created so it says oh or duplicate okay
let me just do 2020 because let's look
forward right so I have a you can see
that the error also came back in the
same thing so it was error 200 but
nevertheless you can see that it came
back with the project and of course the
project name abside Cali 2020 so
mutations I can do subscriptions I can
do a whole bunch of stuff I'm not going
to get into subscriptions because that's
a whole different feature I want to
focus on the attack first so let's get
moving because so Y server listen graph
QL simply because I think it's gonna be
pretty big moving forward you're gonna
see a lot of stacks that are going to
have server less in graph QL especially
for the pricing advantage right
especially for price you're gonna see a
bunch of stacks deployed simply because
it's really cheap running stuff on
server less in graph QL so you would I
would see that this is gonna be a big
business decision that a lot of half of
course in our industry we always have
neo mania right as soon as we see
something new we want a run and jump and
implement it so this is something that
we're going to see with server lesson
graph QL as well I'm sure we will see
this often as we move forward with these
technologies and again it's super easy
to deploy why won't you write this is
the deployment spec for my graph QL and
travel as functional right literally
this that's all it takes
so it's really easy to do so the whole
approach of having to deal with the
deployment and managing the deployment
is really not there so it just becomes
that much easier to work with it Amazon
and a lot of these providers already
provide a lot of tools for it like its
appsync for instance is one of the tools
that allows you to do server lesson
graph QL and it's it's supposed to be
really good I'm not trying it myself but
even without any of those managed
services you can easily run server
lesson graphical together now security
considerations for server is again one
of the things you should keep in mind is
that there is no real framework right
you don't have Jango you don't have
flash you don't have spring you don't
have any of that stuff
you're typically writing your plain old
Python plain old Java plain or
JavaScript etc etc right so you don't
really have input validation or put
encoding you don't have all of the good
stuff that comes with frameworks that's
one of the big challenges with function
is a service of course you don't have
any network attack surface which is nice
observability and debugging is a massive
Payne I don't know how many favorite and
service but you would probably realized
that logging and figuring out what to
what actually the function is doing is a
super painful thing it's it's a pretty
huge challenge and I think a few
companies are trying to solve it but I'm
not sure how good they've gotten with
that of course you have events from
multiple sources which means that you
are attack surface is now gone up quite
a bit okay so I'm going to move forward
a little bit so no frameworks obviously
means no batteries included DIY
validation which means you have to do
everything yourself
and we know all of us know how good we
are at doing such things right so how
good we are as an industry at doing our
own validation doing our own access
control doing our own logging per
function all of that stuff things we
don't do too well we have to end up
doing now a lot off right so that is
something that I believe we're gonna see
a lot of with graph QL and server less
observability I've already mentioned
this I'm going to move on sorry about
that and of course you have events from
multiple sources which means that you
can't just put a wife in front of your
API and forget about it
right you have s3 triggering flowers you
have sqs events triggering flowers you
have events from various sources that
might trigger flus so you have all of
those those security considerations to
think about so traditional security
controls like wharfs or even dashed for
instance will not really work with a lot
of several as functions not all of them
of course but it will not work with a
lot of service functions again graph QL
as well I'm sure we will see some
challenges with a lot of security
tooling working well with right so
useful projects one of course I have to
plug my own project which is of course
it's open source it's damn vulnerable
functions is a service it's on github OS
has a server let's top 10 which you can
look into it also has the guide and an
app associated with it so you should
look into either of these or both of
these really doesn't matter so I'm so
let's start with the attackers view I
have a few demos here and then with
graph QL and then we can so essentially
with functions as a service like I
mentioned before I think one of the
bigger attack vectors that we're going
to see moving forward is with attacking
the functions that are non
HTTP Arnon api gateway driven like for
instance let me give you an example
right so let's say I run a recruitment
company and I allow users to through my
app upload stuff over to s3
write upload their CV is or resumes over
s3 or to s3 now as soon as I upload it
to s3 I trigger an event saying that hey
function read s3 read this file in s3
store it in my dynamodb thing and then
do IA i or whatever analysis i want to
do on top of it after that now let us
say the user uploads a docx file write a
docx file which a lot of people upload
resumes and stuff right now let us say
they uploaded our cux file which is
loaded with the xml external entities
payload and I am parsing the dark X file
with the same vulnerability ml parser I
read it obviously triggers a XML
external entities injection and I point
at that point in time right so you can
see that the attacker is not really
attacking the function per se the
attacker is out-of-band attacking the
function right so it's not more an
out-of-band execution that's happening
with this function and that's why you
are having these kind of triggers so let
me just quickly show you some of the one
other this one one of the examples and
this is called function data event
injection where you inject payloads or
you inject attack vectors through the
non HTTP or out-of-band mess out-of-band
mechanisms that trigger that particular
function right so this of course you can
have over multiple things you can
trigger it over s3 you can trigger it
over the notification service let's say
some messages received where the q and
that messages has some kind of a sequel
injection payload and that is accessed
by a database that would be a pretty big
problem so you can have multiple events
that are causing your injection attacks
to happen right so again this could be
command injection we're going to see
definitely a lot of sequel and no sequel
injection happening as well d
serialization is pretty big and I'll
show you what was one of the some of the
outcomes of attacks that give you access
to our remote code execution to that
particular function right so this
a simple case I'm going to simulate this
case the user uploads an XML file to s3
my function is running a really crappy
parser XML parser which is vulnerable to
XML external entities
I read the XML and of course I the user
is now able to do something which is
malicious write anything malicious so
let's look at our example here and I
have set this up so I'm just going to
upload an XML file and this XML file is
is a malicious XML file I show you what
is happening in this XML file it's
called malicious XML dot XML I'm just
gonna quickly show you what's happening
in here and these examples are in DB
fast by the way so you can if you run DB
fast you will have all of these examples
in the project so this XML file is gonna
pull the HC password and hopefully load
that in the database so what's happening
here is multiple things you have your
function that is triggered as soon as
something is uploaded in s3 so s3 upload
happens object create event is triggered
function reads that XML of course when
it's reading the XML it's using its part
it's going to resolve these entities and
one of the entities it's going to
resolve is HC password so let's look at
what's happening here I'm gonna upload
in this XML of course I'm not directly
attacking the upload feature itself I'm
just uploading to s3 and it's going to
upload and my file it's going to store
in the database and then my file is want
to show up here and you can see that now
I have the Etsy password listed of
course in a function or in a ephemeral
container of VM this may not be too much
of a threat model or it C password may
not mean anything even but you could do
s srf you could let us say a lot of file
stored in the /bin directory you could
have some sensitive file source court
disclosure could happen through these
kind of attacks so you would have some
impact depending upon how your function
is set up and how it's running so this
is an example of a function data event
injection where you're triggering
an attack or an injection payload
through an out-of-band mode and getting
your function to actually fall prey to
it essentially that's what's happening
here the other example that I quickly
have is imagine that you receive a text
message right so Amazon has these
message gateway services like simple
notification service and so on now let
us say you could trigger a function when
a text message came in and this function
let's say your text message has some
sequel injection payload and that's
essentially what the simulation is all
about so this message that we're going
to send is going to have a bunch of
sequel injection payloads so let me just
show you the payloads that I'm talking
about so this is the these are the
payloads it's going on it's going to run
this it's going to send it to the earth
simple notification service and once it
sends it to the simple notification
service my my function would try and
read it of course it's using a
nonparametric sequel statement at this
point in time as a result I trigger a
sequel injection on an insert statement
as opposed to a select statement which
is what you typically see with sequel
injection right so let's look at this
I'm just going to I'm just gonna run
this so I'm just going to deploy the
payloads and if I go back to my database
you would see that I don't know whether
you can see this but you can see that
instead of the actual sensor reading I
have actually been able to dump the
database that the current database the
user on so think of it like sequel
injection with template injection kind
of a payload here where they've actually
been able to trigger a sequel injection
through a text message or an out-of-band
notification service message that comes
in right so these are some of the
attacks that is possible with with
functions as a service I'm going to try
and see if I can do more I've already
seen this again one of the problems with
this obviously challenges it's hard to
test for right you can't test for this
unless you are really you know the you
know the function really well or you are
you are actually security testing teams
are going to find it hard to test for
for sure
you can't deploy rafts and stuff in
front of this simply because you don't
really have the attack coming in over
the API gateway it's coming in over
third
party sources third party notifications
and events so you don't really have
laughs that you can typically deploy for
something like this you of course also
have privilege escalation attacks where
let us say your function is given a lot
of privileges or the role is extremely
loosely scoped and then through that you
can attack other aspects of your AWS or
your cloud service account so let me
just show you a quick screenshot it's
not really a screen shot I think it's
more alive so this is a now this let me
just try and increase the size not able
to zoom in anyway so what's happening
here is I've triggered an insecure DC
realization attack on a function right
now this uses the Python Yambol Darklord
deserialization how many of you are
familiar with that yeah Mel dot Lourdes
utilization technique where I can upload
a arbitrary ml file with Python object
code in it and it would remote code
execute it would just randomly load that
yeah Mel file in in in the in memory so
in this case what's happening is I have
uploaded a malicious payload file which
has which is going to retrieve all the
environment variables of that particular
lambda function and AWS if you are
associated with the ec2 or you're
familiar with EC to EC to has 169 dot
that net that interface which has the
metadata right
the metadata of a function is in the
environment variables so you have your
AWS key ID your secret you have your
session token in the environment
variable so if you can dump the
environment variables you're pretty much
porn to the entire function the role of
the function now you can access as that
functions role and pretty much gain
whatever access you want to that
particular AWS account and the resources
associated with that account so you can
see that it actually has the access key
ID secret key session token all of that
stuff in the environment variable so if
I can dump the environment variables or
some other process related to that I can
actually pull all that data and use that
to escalate privileges on my AWS account
I had another day
but I don't think I'm going to have time
so I'm going to move it quickly I have
there's another one called DynamoDB
injection you can read about it it's on
my medium page it's it was an attack
that I identified about a year back so
that's interesting it kind of relates to
what I'm talking about here I'm going to
quickly go to graph QL because we are
I'm really short on time so graph QL of
course again it's one of those things
that is largely DIY at this point access
control input validation query white
listing all of the good stuff that you
want to do with graph QL you have to do
it yourself right
so unfortunately graph QL does not it
was just like so ever less you still
have a lack of frameworks that allow you
to do a lot of the good security stuff
with graph QL there are I mean they're
building it quite a bit in fact Apollo
and all these frameworks are building in
a lot of safeguards for graph QL like
query whitelisting and so on and so
forth but still if you're using Python
or if you're using let's say go or
whatever it is the tooling for many of
these languages are not that great to be
honest so you still have to do a lot of
this yourself you still have to manage a
lot of this yourself right so attackers
view of graph QL graph QL in many ways
is going to be very similar to a web
application or a web service the kind of
flaws you would see except that we would
see I would I think that we want to see
a lot more authorization flaws I think
we're going to see a lot of no sequel
injection flaws right especially because
no sequel injection graph QL requires
you to kind of loosely scoped the query
when you are searching for things and so
on and so forth so we will see no sequel
injection bugs kind of taking center
stage we are also going to see a lot of
denial of service when it's coupled with
server less I think we're going to see a
ton of denial of service attacks which
will cause your bill to just shoot
through the roof and I'll show you a
demo a little bit later let's move on
one of the things with graph QL is that
it has an ability to do introspection so
which means you can actually query the
API or query the graph QL and come back
with all the fields and objects and
types that it supports right so for
instance let me just quickly query
my graph to our lair with that data I
can actually get all of the different
queries and stuff so I'm gonna just
query run this introspection query and
this will give me all the types that are
in my graphical layer so you can see
that all of the so think of these as
database tables right all of these our
database tables that now I can access
and query and do whatever I want or
typically perform some kind of
operations with I can also go a little
deeper let us say I want a query the
type Wellner ability with all the fields
that is associated with I can say boom
give me all of the vulnerability fields
it will tell you that it has all of
these different fields so when you how
many of you view sequel map and stuff
like that here sequel MapReduce equal
injections you would probably want to
use similar techniques right with sequel
map where you go in and you find the
current database that the tables you'll
dump the tables you dump the rows you'll
dump the column that so on and so forth
you do that as a feature in graph QL I'm
not saying it's a bad feature it's it's
it's meant to be a feature but the idea
is lot of people don't disable
introspection and as a result you kind
of have this entire layer open that -
anyone can query and imagine a lot of
these could be sensitive fields right
let us say one of the examples I'm going
to show later is a field in a user type
which is called is admin now I should
not have to know that is admin is a
field that I can access and do something
with because I can change that and
become admin right so the thing with
graph QL is that if you don't lock down
the introspection layer you can get
willy-nilly at least you you will have a
lot of information disclosure associated
with that okay I'm gonna quickly move
ahead how much time do I have oh oh
sheesh sorry about that I have three
more demos two minutes each is that okay
okay thank you
appreciate it so again I'm gonna move
forward not this introspection of course
we are talking about this introspection
Authorization bypass graft QL I think
we're gonna see a lot of mass assignment
right now this is a vulnerability I
think I don't know when it dates back to
I'd in 2013
is when we saw a lot of mass assignment
in Ruby right Ruby was where we saw a
lot of mass assignment bugs hitting us
in github was compromised based on a
mass assignment flaw in this in this
type of flaw what typically happens is
that the there is a module that you
frame and the attacker essentially sends
all of the fields or all the attributes
serialized in a particular format and it
may be base64 or maybe JSON or whatever
it is and once the application receives
it the application DC realizes and just
dumps that as and creates an object from
that and Dom started to the database now
with graph QL we are likely to see a lot
of these type of attacks simply because
now we have introspection because if an
attacker can gain actual access to an
introspection layer the attacker can
gain access to what are the different
fields in your layer and then start
manipulating some of those fields to
start tampering with authorization
privileges and gain access to a lot of
sensitive functionality that the
attacker should not have this is a video
demo I'm just going to kind of play it
and see it's going to be so I have mass
assignment flow that we have simulated
for this so in here the user should user
has a every user can be an admin if of
course the privileges are granted for
that user so what we're doing is we're
creating a bunch of users and this user
should not have access to administration
so the user should not be able to
manipulate the configuration object and
that's something that we're blocking out
in this in this demo here so the user
does not have access to perform
configuration changes or and so on and
you do have an is admin privilege here
so the user does not have access to
these privileges now if the user tries
to perform this action the user
essentially comes back with a sorry
internal server error you are
unauthorized to perform
however on the update feature of this we
have just provided a JSON where the user
can update with a JSON and if the user
puts in is admin : true in the update
file feature the user now has changed
his status to administrator and the user
can now change the configuration and
obviously update sensitive information
and so on and so forth right change the
configuration and do all of that stuff
right so this kind of attack I'm sure we
will see a lot more of in the graph QL
world injection is something I'm not
gonna look at injection because I think
injection is straightforward I think a
lot of us denial of service is something
that I believe is gonna be pretty big in
the graphical world simply because of
nested statements so let us say let's
take two objects that you are a user and
you can be part of a team and a team can
have multiple users so you can have a
nested query where you can query the
user the team's the user the creams the
user the team the use of the team and
you can create this nested approach and
you can perform a denial of service
attack and this would kind of run all
there are CPU cycles and kill their
function so in this case one of the
videos I'm going to show you next we are
running this in a lambda function where
we have we have this this query the
start of query and we are going to use
so we want to use the user and the teams
that the user is associated with and
we're going to build that query as a
nested query right you can see the teams
and the name of the team and then from
the team we're going to get the user
from the of that particular circuit you
can see that the user the name the team
the name the users again so it's going
like a nested relationship that's coming
down and at the end of the query you'll
see that we have four thousand six
hundred and ninety eight lines of nested
query built in and this takes this is
running on a server as function by the
way Amazon throttled us after this so
what happened was it ran for 40 seconds
and this single query cost us three
dollars which means that if you run this
query let's say thousand requests per
minute if an attacker runs this query
thousand requests per minute you are
lambda bill is going to be eight
thousand dollars give or take so you can
see that it's going to run for about 30
to 40 seconds now it's going to take
whatever time it takes
so this attack essentially took I mean
the single single request cost us three
bucks but if this is scale you can see
that it's gonna cost you thousands of
dollars especially if you are a public
facing site that someone can potentially
do this right so graph QL
I think das is going to be a pretty big
payload especially and especially when
it's on surveillance because several s
one of the big reasons we go in for
service is because of the cost and if
that is kind of shot out the window then
you're gonna see a lot of you know bills
that you want to incur that you don't
want to income right so with that some
conclusions I think that these two
framework are these two pieces of
technology are going to be used quite
extensively moving forward simply
because of the business benefit they
bring in and the deployment benefit that
they bring in however this is largely
currently DIY you have to do this
yourself a lot of this has to be done
yourself so this would require a lot
more discipline in terms of input
validation or put encoding all of the
stuff that we are not traditionally good
as good at as an industry so we need to
really think about how we do this in
terms of deploying stuff for writing
code for service in graph QL security
tooling I think we have a lot to catch
up on especially dynamic testing static
code reviews are tough especially
because a lot of these are cloud
libraries and static code reviews don't
really catch a lot of security flaws
with cloud libraries and so on so I
think there's a lot of work that needs
to go into this thank you I'm sorry for
running over time my twitter handle you
can follow a lot of stuff we do on this
space
thank you very much any questions
you